Bruce Willis.
What a career, right?
"The Fifth Element,"
"The Sixth Sense,"
"The Whole Nine Yards,"
"12 Monkeys."
Zero Oscars.
[ Laughter ]
Quentin Tarantino,
M. Night Shyamalan,
Wes Anderson, Michael Bay,
these are just some
of Bruce’s directors
who refused to be here tonight.
[ Laughter ]
Bruce Willis is what you get
if you isolate the white part
of Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson.
[ Laughter ]
And -- And it’s not just action
movies that made Bruce a star.
He’s actually a great
dramatic actor, too.
I loved "The Sixth Sense."
It’s a great movie.
And it’s a really
impressive performance.
I don’t know how you pretended
not to be embarrassed
while a 10-year-old kid
acted circles around you.
But you did it.
And, uh -- And the ending.
I did not see that twist coming.
I mean I-I shouldn’t spoil it,
but...
I mean, fuck it.
It’s been like 20 years.
It’s so good.
Okay, so, at the end
of "The Sixth Sense,"
Bruce goes back
to making shitty movies.
[ Laughter ]
I had a blast working with Bruce
in a time-travel movie
called "Looper."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, thank you.
So, in the film, uh,
I play a young Bruce Willis,
and he played
a washed-up Bruce Willis.
But it was this crazy
sci-fi premise
where I end up in the future
and Bruce ends up
in a good movie made after 1999.
[ Laughter ]
We want you to have
a good time tonight,
but don’t get too comfortable
up here,
because later,
we’re gonna be replacing you
with Ashton Kutcher.
Relax!
Relax.
Bruce gets along with him fine.
He was even at Ashton
and Demi’s wedding.
His gift was a toaster
and $90 million dollars.
[ Laughter ]